it starts with michael walken walk the
last time out against baltimore
scattered three runs over five innings
against the o's and he's pitched okay
against the yankees in the past
and stepping in is dj la mayhew
see what he does now on one and two the
right-hander delivers swing and a miss
he struck him out at a high fastball
boy 96. here's rugnito door
powerful left-handed batter with the
infield shifted to the right side
wanted to the count to the left-hand
batting odor with stanton on deck torres
blast the pitch swingled and missed
strike three
aldor retired for the new york yankees
it'll be nestor cortes he hasn't got a
record yet but his era is
1.95 and he'll spot that fastball
meadows a lefty hitter
outside a cruise probably the best
hitter on the team now here's the o2
fastballs outside fast oh they called a
strike
home played up by will little little
late called it a strike
so that'll do the inning one two three
go the raise
and at the end of one no score all right
well gary sanchez started here in the
second and the o2 pitch swing at a messy
struck him out great sequence
started him fast balls got him with a
change up and down goes sanchez waka's
third k already
two out base is empty no score leaves it
for
geo er shallow
herschela had a pair of dumbbells
yesterday and the last one drove him two
runs
11 homers and 41 runs batted in block of
pitches swinging a miss at a change in
the dirt mejia blocks it off to the left
comes out in front of home plate and
pegs it down to first in time four
[Music]
they out to complete the strikeout it
goes two to three and waka with two
strikeouts in each the first and second
innings after one and a half lao at 224
i know a terrible batting average a much
better hit than that here's the o2
struck him out swinging fastball away
he got a fastball when he needs it
and he puts it in the right spot two
down
randy arose arena he's at 257 cortes
will deal
2-2
and the pitch is strike three fastball
beneath
third strikeout for cortez he continues
his terrific pitcher
well two innings in the books so with
one out here is esteban florio
294 in the air with a home run a couple
of runs batted in
not in the original lineup but then when
judge was scratched he was inserted
moved down to the number nine spot
linkie left-handed hitter again the rays
incorporate the shift
for him
now walker ready with another o2 pitch
swinging and a miss he struck him out
michael walker
with a handful of strikeouts one time
through two go on yeah nine batters
faced five strikeouts and only 36
[ __ ] so with
a runner at first base here's labor tour
as he walked his first time
the 3-2 pitch runner goes swung on and
missed strike three six strikeouts
all ready for michael walka as he gets
torres swinging
here is brett phillips one two is cut
out of missed good fastball by cortez
struck him out for a strikeout for
nestle
here's john carlos standing bounce to
second bases only time hit it hard but
right to brandon low
a little number to the right side long
way to go for loud he shuffles that ball
to first to get it there to diaz in time
to get the out on stanton
so with one out and runner at second
base here is gary sanchez
now the
2-2 on its way swimming in a mess
hey
struck him out of sanchez out on strikes
for the second time and that's seven
strikeouts already
here's brett gardner he fly to left
field go to pitch swinging and a miss
he
struck him out and it's eight strikeouts
for walking here is yandy diaz now with
one on and one out we are scoreless
bottom of the fourth and deals one two
to diaz cut out a miss struck him out
swinging
and that is strikeout number five
for cortes so two ounce runner at first
base brandon lau
gets to home plate pitch from cortez
lifted down the right field line it's
gonna get down and go to the wall flying
around second on its way to third as
franco he's going to get the wave home
relay throw by odor to the plate is too
late in the third base goes brandon lau
the rays take a one-nothing lead here
are the four
so it'll be first and third with two men
out
and
that will bring up left hand hitting
joey wendell
pitch is swung on and lined to left
field right at gardner who makes the
catch
and that ends the inning
so cortes gets through with only one run
one run
two hits and
two left
now the end of four names of play one
nothing ranges first sighting of aaron
judge in the dugout tonight
we had not seen him he was scratched
from the lineup earlier so now judge is
in fact in the lineup or in the dugout
should i say he's grabbed that helmet
too
do up for the yankees or show up
pitch a chopper to third wendell great
short hop throws it away
yankees get a break and here comes aaron
judge lorraine's right-hander pitches
swing and a miss he struck him out
a changeup down and judge retired one
away
that matches a season high nine
strikeouts for michael walkup
and it's dj le mayhew
who has struck out and single pitch
is lemay who swings with the fly ball to
center phillips makes a catch here comes
her shella here comes the throw not in
time
it's a sac fly and an rbi
for lemay you and the yankees tie the
game at one
it'll leave it for gleber torres who's
walked and fanned waka to the belt he
does look at second base allen goes back
to the base of the pitch slice to right
caught by the first baseman diaz he
saved a run
two outs now for the yankees in the
eighth and here's stanton
the two
swing and a fly ball
right field not deep margot coming in
gets underneath it makes the catch and a
great job by matt whistler to keep this
a tie game
somebody's going to win this game in
their final at back
all right well here is urshella now
here's whistler and the two strength
pitch to ershello line drive to second
caught by lyle race to the bag double
play
[Music]
tyler wade could not get back to second
on the soft liner by urshella and the
reigns turn their first double play of
the night just in the nick of time
franco won for three on the night
now here is greens 2-1
and a breaking ball is grounded up the
first baseline green fields flips to
first and there's one away
michelle at second greg allen at first
and the hitter is aaron judge and the
pitch
grounded and off the glove of franco and
into center field
coming home is urchella he will score
moving to third is allen judge drives in
the run it's 2-1
yankees we'll see how they score it
and they give him a base hit a huge
break
huge break for the yankees
and fairbanks is going to leave so you
want to talk about
can things get a whole lot worse
he just gave up a lead to the yankees
and now you're
one of your highest leverage
laid any guys has to walk off the mount
after just throwing a handful of pitches
lemayos already knocked in a run on a
sac fly boy the yankees would love one
more sac fly
and the pitch and that one gets away
from mejia scoring easily is allen and
moving to second his judge is 3-1
yankees
kitridge ready with a 1-2 swinging a
ground ball right side they'll get
judged the third low has it throws to
first and that's out number one
grace will bring the infield in again
for
labor tourists in a 2-1 pitch
swing in a line drive caught by wendell
at third scampers for the bag he doubles
up judge and that will
retire the side a line out double play
goes five unassisted
so the batter is francisco mejia switch
it or batting right
now chapman is ready
to pitch to mahia
and the pitches popped up
he popped him up in the infield there is
lemayo near first lemay who
makes a catch he fell down and caught
the ball before it hit the ground wow
what a way to end the game
wow ball game over yankees win
yankees win